nueva semana de actualización del
ranking de la atp y de la doblete
respectivamente con protagonismo
argentino comenzamos con la
clasificación masculina porque diego
suárez man entra por primera vez en su
carrera entre los 10 mejores del
circuito esto tras llegar a semifinales
en roland garros el peque zen dio seis
plazas y se convirtió en el primer
jugador de su país en llegar al 'top
ten' en más de ocho años de otra parte
en el cuadro femenino la polaca y tec
irrumpe en el top 20 de la campeona de
roland garros de apenas 19 años gana 37
puestos y es ahora la 17 del mundo la
argentina nadie ha podrás cada por su
parte gana 83 posiciones y ahora es el
ranking 48 del mundo recordemos que la
rosarina alcanzó las semifinales de
roland garros en su debut en un debut
histórico en este torneo llegando desde
la clasificación y alcanzando las
semifinales en hora buena para argentina